calling in sick for work that's some of
the best acting work we ever do in our
entire lives I was writing on a sitcom
last year I needed a particular day off
yeah not that way you need a particular
day off and you're like I could ask for
that day off but if they don't give it
to me I'm still not gonna be there that
day so I'm gonna have to go with a call
in sick it's gonna have to call it's a
burden but sideways on you it's on your
own personal calendar I got that stay I
got a call in sick
that's the day I gotta do my three-day
acting tour de force because when I call
and say I don't just call in sick on the
call and sick they I start acting sick
around the office two days prior to the
call in sick day yeah that like it'll be
like a few days before you're gonna
start pretending you're sick it's the
work front that's gonna Hotel in this
happen one time the guy always like
we're gonna be alone on Sunday I was
gonna call it Sunday it's just gonna be
me and you outside I already took a look
at the schedule we're gonna be getting
slammed so make sure you're ready my
head I go to him yeah no absolutely man
I'll be ready gotta be double ready
you have no idea how slammed you're
gonna be on set day you feel bad but you
can't tell them you always wanna be like
yeah I just want you to prepare for the
storm I'm [ __ ] cold and sick on trip
that's what I do three days prior to the
call in sick day I just thought acting a
little sick little things a little
coffee here and there
normally I drink coffee but instead I
have tea through a hard dip with a bag
until someone sees and want some let me
see this somebody's like you're drinking
tea coffee usually I know something like
throw some skunk down and see you
what time I was acting sick throwing the
guys like well man you sound bad you
should probably go home and take it
getting sick
oh my head I'm like no no I'll be sick
Wednesday I'm fine today Wednesday
Wednesday Pacific I don't act much white
all really movies and TV I did a show
once and the director apparently was at
the show we wanted to meet me in the
green room they're like he's a fan of
yours
he's a important guy I had very little
time I couldn't even google him so I
walked him to meet the guy and he's like
hey nice to meet ya
nice to meet you big fan of your work
which what'd you say that's what you say
your it says is like thanks cuz I'm a
real big fan of you and your stuff and
he goes do you do any acting a lot of
act like what's the last thing I may
have ever seen you act in so we said so
I just want to be that guy this room two
minutes ago I said I'm a fan of your
work I don't even know who you are and
you so well good I got it I get out I
don't think is the accent that's why I
don't really do a lot of acting I don't
why I'm having a very thick could you
tell I mean can you tell him from Kansas
sir
I don't mind never my New York Long
Island accent it is what it is baby but
let's be honest you know the minute you
start talking with this accent nobody
ever thinks oh it is a genius I wish I
could lose the accent sometimes that's
all like my wife and I went to get a
mortgage on the house I had to get a
bank loan before we walk in my wife goes
when we go in there try not to sound all
goombah right away - Bank lady comes up
she's I could afternoon I'm like hey how
you doing yeah that's just to walk away
to get some my wife looks at me how you
doin how you doing pretty order and a
pastrami sandwich at a deli
you